if that pocket dimension cracks if they
escape i'll watch
i have nothing but time thank you steven
and besides what are friends for
you might want to brace yourself
the hydra stomper yeah
and there's someone inside
[Music]
welcome back everyone this will be my
new marvel what if episode 9 post credit
scene video in season 2 teaser they also
use a lot of the other ending scene
moments with the characters to set up
what's going to be happening in season 2
including paying off the missing iron
man episode so if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos i will do videos for what
if season 2 when it starts and i will be
doing videos for hawkeye episodes that's
actually the next big marvel disney plus
series that we're getting episodes for
before the end of the year real quick
spoiler warning if you have not seen
what if episode 9 we'll be talking about
everything that happened but at the end
of the episode dark doctor strange in
the watcher work together to trap
killmonger with the infinity armor who's
fighting ultron who's been taken over by
arnhem zola's ai that's also right out
of the comics too arnhem zola putting
himself in a robot body and then
manifesting the stomach face but doctor
strange traps them inside a pocket
dimension and then keeps them within his
pocket dimension so it's like a pocket
dimension inside a pocket dimension and
he's just going to watch them now like
the watcher watches the entire
multiverse you could call this version
of doctor strange a watcher in training
they haven't confirmed whether or not
he's coming back during season two but i
believe that they will bring this
character back just because they spent
so much time developing him and he plays
such an important role in the multiverse
now you also have to remember that this
version is way more powerful than mcu
doctor strange even though when we get
to doctor strange multiverse of madness
and spider-man no way home our main
version of doctor strange inside the mcu
main universe will be the most powerful
that he's ever been with the exception
of scarlet witch wielding the darkhold
he is supposed to be the most powerful
sorcerer in the universe but as he's
sending all the characters back peggy
carter's captain carter asks for the
avengers end game ending that they gave
captain america in the main universe to
send her back to 1942 so that she can
have a similar ending moment going back
to her version of steve rogers the way
that captain america went back to be
with peggy carter in 1942 even though he
has the power to do that he claims that
he can't do that because this era the
era that he pulled her from in present
day of her universe needs captain carter
that's a bit of a lead-in for what if
season two because she will be coming
back during season two this version of
captain carter but it's also set up for
the big payoff with the hydra stomper
version of the winter soldier in that
post-credits scene like this hydra
stomper winter soldier version of steve
rogers needs captain carter and as we
learn from that dark doctor strange
scene when he's holding that pocket
universe he tells the watcher you knew
everything that was going to happen
before it happened so that means that
the watcher knew that peggy carter was
going to meet the hydra stomper winter
soldier which is why he said no i can't
send you back this era needs captain
carter and as he sends her back to the
exact moment that she left from she
still mid-fight with that version of
batroc the leaper her version of black
widow does her solid and takes him out
with the widow sting then claims the
whole reason why his group was on this
ship was to steal the hydra stomper
winter soldier they didn't say who they
were there to steal it for but it's
probably something related to nick fury
during the winter soldier movie the
whole idea in the winter soldier movie
if it wasn't clear is that they were
there to mask what was going on with the
big hydra plot with those big
helicarriers there was the arnhem zola
ai that they were trying to get
information on so it was all about nick
fury trying to find out what was really
going on inside shield people keeping
secrets within the organization in
unmasking what hydra was really doing
because he never fully trusted the other
people that he was working under and
shield so what they're trying to imply
here is that this is basically a version
of skinny boy steve rogers in the hydra
stopper who has somehow captured by
hydra after the end of episode one and
turned into a version of the winter
soldier with a few big twists instead of
revolving around the super soldier serum
that they gave to bucky to turn him into
winter soldier along with the
brainwashing this is all about the hydra
stomper technology so they just gave him
upgraded versions of the hydra stomper
over eras as they unthawed him for
missions he looks like he's being kept
in an actual prison cell and you see all
this cold storage gear around him so the
idea is that they put him on ice and
unthaw him and that's how he survived
the present day same way that bucky
survived the present day although also
having the super soldier serum slows
down the aging process for him so it's a
little bit different for bucky but then
the whole season two teaser here where
they're basically setting up an episode
for her is where they do a winter
soldier episode but it's the hydra
stomper so he's been brainwashed and she
has to bring him back the same way that
steve rogers tried to bring back bucky
obviously he got a lot of help in the
mcu like you have shuri deprogramming
him where basically he has all this ptsd
that they don't really pay off and deal
with until you get to the falcon winter
soldier series the what if episodes tend
to blow through the plots of the marvel
movies so i have a feeling by the end of
whatever winter soldier episode that
they do during season 2 where they pay
all this stuff off he'll be much closer
to coming back to his senses than winter
soldier was after the winter soldier
movie for those of you complaining about
not getting that iron man cicar episode
they dropped a lot of teasers for that
during the episode the showrunner
basically claimed that we would see that
episode during season two like they had
shifted it fully to season two the only
minor changes that they have to make to
that episode just add a few things just
to bring it into continuity with what's
going to be happening with the
overarching plot in season 2 with
whoever the new main villain is and the
new reason for the guardians and the
multiverse to cross over but one of the
quotes that the showrunner gave about it
is she said wait till you see how gamora
got that armor so the iron man sikar
episode will be one of the early
episodes of season two maybe not the
first episode but one of the first
episodes if you re-watch that scene in
the episode they actually kind of give
you a pretty good idea for what happened
the basic idea is that iron man and
gamora get sent to sakaar instead of
thor and the hulk and they wind up
having to battle each other in the
contest of champions in because he's
wearing that trash buster armor like the
iron man armor made from all the
technology that he dumpster dive while
he was on zakar the grandmaster forces
them to fight and then they have to go
up against thanos with another version
of the infinity gauntlet and use the
infinity crusher to get rid of that
universe's version of the infinity
stones after which they melt down their
version of the infinity gauntlet like
the scene as it played out in the
episode was actually meant to be what
happened after the end of that episode
the same way that they revisited the
plots of all the episodes when they were
collecting all the heroes in the finale
like you see what happened after the big
wtf ending cliffhangers so it sounds
like the plot of that iron man cicar
episode basically played out the same
way the timeline of thor ragnarok
through the post credit scene in thanos
showing up at the very beginning of
avengers infinity war played out the
other big thing they confirmed for
season two the other big teasers the
showrunner was dropping is that they
would incorporate plots and characters
from the brand new marvel phase four
stuff that's been happening in the new
movies in the new disney plus series so
like characters and plot from one
division like a version of agatha
harkness from a different universe a
version of upgraded scarlet witch with
more powerful chaos magic in the
darkhold like billy and tommy loki
characters like king the conqueror loki
variants like sylvie the tva characters
like owen wilson's mobius and renslayer
may be alligator loki hopefully i feel
like he would be perfect for animation
but the showrunner also mentioned
characters from the shangshi movie
eternals characters including the
celestials which i'm actually hoping for
too like everybody was thinking of
galactus when they had that big episode
8 twist where the version of ultron ate
the galaxy doing really weird really
cosmic stuff is perfect for animation
just because there's no budgetary
constraints for stuff like that and as
you saw during the marvel zombies
episode they didn't have any problem
doing a version of spider-man so there
will be spider-man stuff happening
during season two but they've written
all the scripts so i don't know if we're
gonna see a lot of stuff with sinister
six characters or spider-man no way home
plot it also means we probably won't see
fantastic four characters or big x-men
characters until like what if season 3
or season 4 until those movies actually
happen inside the mcu but with each new
season however many seasons they go like
four or five seasons they'll just work
in new characters that we've just seen
in the brand new marvel movies in marvel
phase 4 marvel phase 5 eventually and
even though they are bringing back the
guardians of the multiverse season to
season the idea is that they'll cycle
most of the roster the only person
they've confirmed is coming back is
captain carter here but they could be
bringing back other characters too and
the movie actors will also come back to
play their characters from yet other
different universes probably the best
example of that is that chadwick boseman
mayhe rest in peace played four
different versions of black panther
during the what if episodes so you'll
see other mcu actors doing that too with
other versions of characters in future
seasons and while the show runner had
been teasing season two plot in the
episodes of what was going to be
happening she also revealed that they
had been developing a full-blown what-if
spin-off series just for chadwick
boseman's version of t'challa star-lord
like they were going to do a t'challa
star-lord series by itself obviously
that was in development before he passed
away but the idea is that any of these
big what-if characters alternate
universe versions are fair game to get
their own big spin-off if the movie
actors are down to do that they even
just announced a full-blown live-action
one division spin-off for agatha
harkness everyone cue the music it was
agatha all along
[Music]
the idea with that series is that i'll
just explore more of her timeline like
what happens after marvel phase four the
last time we saw at the end of juan
division and more of what happened in
her past because she's been around since
the salem witch trials she'll also come
back during future marvel movies as well
too not just this new full-blown ag of
the harkness series but if there's any
big easter eggs that you spotted in the
post-credits scene that i didn't talk
about during this or any big questions
that you have about what if season 2
just write them below in the comments
and i'll address it in my future bonus
videos hawkeye episodes are starting in
a couple weeks we'll also get a new
hawkeye trailer pretty soon too they
just released a new eternals trailer
video so i'll do a video for that
there's a bunch of big trailers that
just dropped so i'll try to get to those
as fast as possible and next week
there's a brand new batman movie trailer
and dc fandom coming with a bunch of
trailers for the dc movies of course
i'll do all the videos for that stuff so
make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel to be the first to see those
everyone click here for my full what if
episode 9 finale video and click here
for my brand new house of the dragon
trailer video in game of thrones easter
eggs thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys
in the next one
[Music]
you